un débat demandé par le groupe
communiste pour faire le bilan de
l'impact du dispositif sur l'emploi et
la recherche en france
alors le crédit impôt recherche il
existe depuis plus de 30 ans l'objectif
c'est d'encourager les entreprises à
renforcer leurs investissements en
recherche et développement
ici au sénat un rapport a été fait
l'année dernière sur le seuil r mais il
n'a pas été publié le rapport était en
effet assez critique pour la rapporteure
communiste brigitte gonthier maurin le
crédit impôt recherche n'est pas
efficace en matière d'emploi surtout il
est utilisé comme instrument
d'optimisation fiscale voilà donc tout
de suite je vous propose de suivre les
débats dans l'hémicycle
autour de cette question monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues alors que la dépense
budgétaire directe est régulièrement
soumises à contrôle et évaluation
il semble ne pas en être de même pour la
dépense fiscale
en témoigne le sort réservé au rapport
de la commission d' enquête sur le
crédit d'impôt recherche
créé à l'initiative du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen dont j'étais la
rapporteure décrété la sanctuarisation
d'une créance publique qui atteint
aujourd'hui les 5,5 milliards d'euros
dans le plf 2016 ne saurait couper court
aux interrogations au débat et à
l'exigence d'évaluation c'est la raison
pour laquelle mon groupe s'est mobilisé
pour la tenue de ce débat
rappelons que le cir et le transfert
consentis par l'état au nom du
contribuable pour que les dépenses de
recherche des entreprises privées
progressent significativement et ainsi
contribuer à une reprise de croissance
durable entre 2007 et 2012
le cir a bondi de 1,8 à 5,3 milliards
d'euros suite à la réforme réalisée sous
le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy au
début des années 2000 cette créance
detec de 500 millions vous me répondrez
que cela n'a rien d'anormal pour un
outil qui se veut incitatif cependant
attractivité ne signifie pas
automatiquement efficacité c'est ce que
montrait le projet de rapport que ça
avait proposé aux membres de la
commission
enquête car incontestablement les
données macroéconomiques ne sont pas
rassurantes quant à la conformité du cir
aux attentes fixées par le législateur
c'est à dire au regard des efforts de
r&d réellement consenti par les
entreprises et leurs effets positifs sur
l'emploi scientifique
premier constat si la charge du sirha
considérablement augmenter la dépense
intérieure de recherche et de
développement des entreprises n'a pas
suivi le profil d'augmentation
correspondant avec une créance de cir en
accroissement de 3,5 milliards d'euros
entre 2007 et 2012
on se serait attendu à une progression
de la dirn comprise entre 10,5 et 14
milliards d'euros compte tenu du taux de
couverture de la dépenses de r&d par le
cir
en réalité la dirn et en 2012 supérieur
que de 5,3 milliards d'euros par rapport
à son niveau de 2007 et cela pour un
nombre de brevets à thoune il existe
donc bien un décalage entre l'avantagé
fiscal consenti et son effet pour
atténuer la perception de ce décalage
les promoteurs du cir font état d'une
intensification de la r&d dont le projet
de rapport démontrait d'ailleurs le
manque de sérieux
une méthode alternative de justification
de l'efficacité du cir a été fréquemment
mentionné les fameuses estimation
économétrique nous avons auditionné des
économistes les deux principales
méthodes employées ne permettent pas
décrire cette équation je recommandais
donc la réalisation d'une étude
économétrique pluraliste et donc
incontestable le nombre de déclarants a
également été démultiplié en 2008 les
bénéficiaires regroupait 8950 est une
entité la loi de finances 2015 faisais
état de seize mille deux cents
entreprises
émargeant au cir celle de 2016 en pointe
désormais à 1465 le dispositif est donc
loin d'être stabilisé
il est particulièrement intéressant de
s'intéresser à la mesure des facteurs de
l'augmentation du cir observée ces
dernières années la marge intensive a
joué avec une augmentation soudaine de
l' avantage accordé aux grandes
entreprises leurs efforts de r&d
n'augmente pas entre 2007 et 2009
en revanche leurs créances de six
doubles ou triples parfois cela ne veut
pas dire que sur le long terme
le cir soit des pour eu d'effets
positifs mais il est beaucoup trop tôt
pour s'en persuader
ce qui bouge vraiment c'est la marge
extensive c'est à dire le nombre
d'entreprises qui entrent dans le
dispositif faisait tel de la r&d
auparavant sont-elles nouvelles d'où
vient-elle sont-elles indépendante telle
est leur devenir
sont-elles racheter si elle ne meurt pas
et par qui quelles fonctionnalités le
cir assume-t-il vraiment pour elle à ces
questions peu de réponses car il
n'existe pas d'outil de suivi cela
mérite pourtant attention car nous
savons que ces pme souvent fragiles voit
dans le sirh un autre outil fiscal le
moyen de financement qui leur fait
défaut auprès des banques
autre incertitude la nature des dépenses
éligibles
un des principaux motifs de redressement
fiscal
ces dépenses sont elles réellement
progresser l'état de l'art
le projet de rapport mettait en évidence
en évidence des zones de flou notamment
dans le domaine informatique et des
professions financières à ces constats
s'ajoute celui d'une sous administration
patente
souvent présentée comme simple efficace
le cir n'est en fait que peu maîtrisée
peut contrôler faute simplement de
moyens dédiés suffisant en matière de
contrôle fiscal son taux de couverture
est très faible le chiffre avancé de 7 %
d'un une image trop flatteuse de la
réalité amalgamant le nombre de
redressement et le nombre de déclarants
carats pour un même déclarante
dizaines de redressement peuvent
intervenir en réalité le taux de
couverture du cir n'est pas susceptible
d'être supérieur au taux de couverture
moyen de l'impôt sur les sociétés soit
1,7 pour cent environ et peut-être même
moins contenue du nombre de dossiers à
examiner un cir a donc une chance sur
cent à peu près d'être contrôlé de plus
en dessous d'une certaine quantité on ne
le contrôle pas compte tenu de
l'explosion des petits créanciers selon
revient tout de même à ne pas vérifier
d'emblée quelques 30 % de la créance de
surcroît ce dispositif offre des
possibilités d'optimisation fiscale
scandaleuse à travers le lieu
d'immatriculation de certains brevets la
pratique des prix de transfert et la
localisation dans des paradis fiscaux
des entités percevant des redevances
découlant des brevets brevets qui pour
partie sont financées par du cir
quid alors pour le tissu économique
industriel français pour l'emploi
scientifique du retour sur
investissement de la mobilisation d'une
telle créances publiques
le cir est aussi une véritable aubaine
pour des cabinets de conseil dont les
comportements prédateurs nous ont été
décrits ainsi les tarifs pratiqués par
ces intermédiaires réduisent plus ou
moins l'impact positif du cir sur les
bilans des entreprises d'un montant qui
dépasse les 150 millions d'euros
un mot également sur le chevauchement
des assiettes du cir et du cic le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi avec
possibilité de cumuler ces deux
avantages fiscaux
il existe un principe d'assiette du cir
qui est la soustraction d autres
subventions publiques accordées aux
entreprises afin d'éviter un cumul
davantage or cette règle n'est pas
appliquée au cic en découle un
chevauchement qui certes ne concerne pas
l'ensemble de l'assiette du cir mais une
partie celle correspondant aux
rémunérations les moins élevés ce
chevauchement d'assiette pourrait
représenter entre 360 et 600 millions
d'euros pour un coût de cire compris
entre 120 et 200 millions
j'avais donc proposé la suppression pure
et simple de cette duplication davantage
et j'ai d'ailleurs réitéré cette
proposition lors du plf 2016 qu'en
est-il enfin des effets du cir sur
l'emploi sont ici qu'on nous indique que
le nombre de chercheurs dans les
entreprises privées a beaucoup augmenté
en france il existe sur ce point de très
fortes interrogations qui sont ces
chercheurs
essentiellement des ingénieurs de plus
on constate une baisse significative de
la durée du travail des chercheurs en
entreprise qui conduit à supposer que
beaucoup d'entre eux sont en situation
de multi-activités venant de
compartiments du secteur public de la
recherche où il continue d'exercer leur
profession
quant à l'effet d'entraînement du cir
sur l' embauche des jeunes docteurs il
est quasi nulle sur les requalifications
de personnel au titre de la recherche
votre ministère de ce ministre ne dit
pas le besoin d'évaluer dans quelle
mesure certains emplois ont été indûment
déclaré dans le cadre du site tout en
considérant cette évaluation non
prioritaires je ne partage pas cet avis
par contre ce qui est manifeste c'est
que le ci représente un allègement
massive du coût de l'emploi scientifique
or il est intéressant de noter que ce
sont les pays où le coût du chercheur
est le plus élevé qui ont des niveaux de
r&d de leur entreprise est plus fort de
plus ce dispositif par trop aveugle ne
permettait pas ne permet pas de cibler
deux grandes priorités de relance
industrielle et s'articule difficilement
avec les grands chantiers prioritaires
que le gouvernement a fixé
j'ai en mémoire le propos d'un grand
groupe international estimant que le cir
je cite par l'indétermination de son
régime constitue un outil dangereux
il est donc urgent à minima d'encadrer
ce dispositif
c'est ce que j'avais proposée consciente
de l'absence de consensus en faveur
d'une réforme plus radicale pour
permettre à tout le moins de sécuriser
un dispositif qui ne l'est pas et même
d'en renforcer l'efficience
or tout a été rejeté en bloc
quel dommage cela ne peut qu'alimenter
la suspicion à l'égard du cir qui au
final s'apparente davantage à un
abaissement de l'impôt sur les sociétés
plutôt qu'une stimulation efficace de la
r&d des entreprises privées mes chers
collègues le législateur a la
responsabilité de s'interroger sur les
âges de l'efficacité de la mobilisation
d'un tel volume de dépenses publiques
il s'agit là d'un impératif démocratique
d'autant que dans même temps la
recherche publique est maintenu dans un
état de paupérisation et de
précarisation 3,6 vous remercie merci
madame anne gonthier maurin qui me soit
permis de saluer et de remercier les
militaires qui sont ici dans cette
tribune de la section vigipirate
merci
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
madame françoise laborde pour six
minutes madame françoise laborde
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le progrès
et l'innovation constituent des leviers
essentiels à la relance de la croissance
pour pallier à la faiblesse chronique
des dépenses des entreprises françaises
en matière de recherche et développement
la montée en puissance du crédit d'impôt
recherche décidé en 2008 avait pour
objectif de renverser cette tendance
qu'en est il aujourd'hui avec 5,5
milliards d'euros le crédit d'impôt
recherche est devenu l'aide fiscale en
faveur de la recherche et développement
la plus avantageuse des pays membres de
l' ocde
l'évaluation de cette dépense publique
est impérative au regard de son coût
élevé pour nos finances publiques et des
efforts ainsi consentis par les
contribuables
la création de la commission denquête
devait contribuer à vérifier la
légitimité de cet inventaire
interventions publiques et je regrette
donc qu'un accord n'ait pu être conclu
en vue d'autoriser la publication de son
rapport
nul ne contexte ne conteste que le
crédit d'impôt recherche génère des
effets positifs pour la recherche dans
notre pays
en effet la dépense en recherche et
développement des entreprises augmenter
de 19,2 pour cent entre 2008 et 2013
dans un contexte de crise économique et
le niveau de la dir a atteint 6 1,46
pour son du pib' en 2014 ce qui place la
france au sixième rang mondial et au
deuxième rang européen en matière
d'emplois scientifiques le bilan est
également favorable avec 33 mille
chercheurs supplémentaires embauchées
depuis 2008
mais ces critères sont est suffisant
pour caractériser son efficacité le
nombre de brevets déposés et de
publications scientifiques peinent
encore à décoller et une fois la
recherche aboutit son exploitation et
délocalisent
par ailleurs la commission denquête a
orienté ses travaux sur le détournement
du cir
il y a tout d'abord il faut le dire un
détournement qui est autorisé par la loi
car ces dépenses ne finisse pas
uniquement la recherche
on ne peut ainsi reproché à des
entreprises d'optimiser leur imposition
à partir du moment où elles agissent
dans le cadre de la légalité même si
cela est bien sûr contestable je pense
par exemple au calcul du seuil de 100
millions filiale par filiale au lieu
d'un calcul au niveau du groupe
fiscalement intégré ou encore au cumul
avec le crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi portant sur
les mêmes assiettes
il y a ensuite le détournement au sens
de la fraude qui doit être sévèrement
sanctionnés et les contrôles fiscaux en
la matière sont lourds
il est ainsi complexe de se faire une
idée précise du rapport coût efficacité
de ce dispositif
la recherche française qu'elle soit
privée ou publique souffrent d'autres
mots à savoir la complexité
administrative et la stabilité normative
et financière
le baromètre de l'attractivité de la
france pour 2015 effectuée par un
cabinet de conseil démontre que
l'environnement administratif et
juridique constitue l'une des
principales préoccupations des
entreprises
c'est notamment le cas des petites
entreprises françaises lise qui lorsqu
elles réussissent ne parviennent pas à
surmonter les effets de seuils ou à
croître en taille
pourtant 90 % du cir bénéficie aux pme
certes le crédit d'impôt recherche
participe pleinement à l'attractivité de
la france
toutefois il ne doit pas être le seul
argument à retenir dans un contexte de
concurrence fiscale internationale
nous devons agir sur l'ensemble dès
leviers possibles pour créer un
environnement propice à l'investissement
d'autres pays de l' ocde font mieux sans
pour autant disposer d'une niche fiscale
aussi généreuse la cour des comptes
rappelait dans son rapport publié en
2013 que ce dispositif ne peut être
regarder uniquement comme une aide
il doit être considéré comme une baisse
de la fiscalité des entreprises exposées
à la concurrence internationale
il contre balance ainsi un taux facial
d'imposition sur les sociétés très élevé
par conséquent réformer cette niche
impliquerait de remettre à plat
l'ensemble de notre fiscalité
le rapport de l' ocde sur la politique
de l'innovation de la france publié en
2014 recommande de baisser la pression
fiscale généreuse en général et en
parallèle de procéder à une diminution
du poids du crédit d'impôt recherche en
estimant que lorsque ce dernier est trop
élevé son effet est par l'ensemble
des autres facteurs qui affectent la
dépense en recherche et développement
mais tel ne semble pas être la voie
empruntée par le gouvernement à défaut
et conformément aux recommandations de
la cour des comptes pour des raisons
évidentes de stabilité de visibilité
pour les entreprises
il serait plus pertinent de le modifier
à la marge en vue de le simplifier la
sécurité juridique favorise l'accueil
des entreprises sur notre territoire et
surtout leur maintien ainsi un ciblage
vers les dépenses relevant exclusivement
de la recherche mériterait d'être
effectué enfin les relations entre les
entreprises l'administration fiscale
étant essentielle la création par la loi
de finances rectificative pour 2015
votée en décembre dernier d'un comité
consultatif pour le crédit d'impôt
recherche sera d'une grande utilité
il devrait faciliter la conciliation des
parties en cas de redressement
de même la dématérialisation des
procédures de déclaration va dans le bon
sens
elle permettra en outre d'avoir un suivi
plus rapide de la dépense bien que tout
indiquait que le crédit d'impôt
recherche allait atteindre rapidement la
barre des 7 milliards d'euros
son montant a pu être contenu celui ci
demeurant très élevé ce débat devait
avoir lieu
et je tiens à saluer l'excellent travail
de la commission denquête et bien sûr de
brigitte gonthier-maurin je vous
remercie
merci madame françoise laborde
la parole est à monsieur francis
delattre pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs cette commission denquête que
j'ai eu l'honneur de présider a
malheureusement été ouverte sur un
malentendu pensons propre intitulé la
réalité du détournement du crédit
d'impôt recherche détournée de son objet
et ses incidences sur la situation de
l'emploi et de la recherche d'autres
pays
d'emblée le mot détournement été
prononcé on pouvait dès lors
s'interroger sur l'objectivité
une telle affirmation est naturellement
et selon la sélection d auditionner par
madame la rapporteure naturellement
s'inscrivait en filigramme la teneur du
rapport final j'ai donc veiller au
pluralisme des auditions sans jamais
renier l'intérêt de contrôler par le
parlement une dépense fiscale importante
de l'ordre de 5 milliards et demi
d'euros
la centaine d'auditions menées quatre
mois durant nous a permis de visiter les
grands centres de la fare développement
de notre pays
en région parisienne à grenoble à nice
et de rencontrer les vrais acteurs de la
recherche développement
nous avons été impressionnés par la
capacité d'innovation des chercheurs
français qui sont de véritables pépites
pour notre pays et ce terme pépites à
d'ailleurs été repris ces jours derniers
par les médias anglo saxons à l'occasion
du consumer electronics show qui se
tient à las vegas en ce moment où il ya
une compétition entre les meilleures
startups des grands pays développés les
est réjouissant de constater que dans
notre pays il ya des chercheurs bien
formés
qui met on pourra les innovations que
demain le monde s'arrache c'est ainsi
qu'il est apparu très vite que le cir
est parfaitement en phase avec les
besoins du pays
ceux d'aujourd'hui indéniablement ce
dispositif est un élément d'attractivité
de la france elle a besoin influent
positivement sur le choix d'entreprises
étant étrangère on regarde leurs
implantations dans le monde étant
précisé que le cir contribuer à réduire
de 10 % moyenne le coût des ingénieurs
de la chaire développement
la véritable actualité monsieur à collex
sur les outils françaises qui ont pris
aujourd'hui les positions stratégiques
en recherche développement notamment
dans l'automobile
mais naturellement reste l'immense
problème du financement de leurs
applications sur le territoire national
où elles connaissent naturellement un
problème d'accès aux financements à
moyen et long terme faute d'une vraie
politique favorisons le capital risque
lors des auditions les plus dures
critiques ont évidemment elmaleh le
chercheur
visiblement militants de la recherche
publique qui déplorait ne parlera c'est
le moyen alors que les entreprises
effectivement profitent de moyens en
développement mais ce n'était pas le
sujet vraiment le dispositif permet
pourtant de cofinancer et c'est pas si
connu une partie de la sarce public dans
des projets mixtes
ce qui nous a été confirmée par le
directeur des études du cnrs qui estime
à 500 millions émanant du cir
contributif à des projets mixtes
cette orientation avec une meilleure
application avec les universités et
l'armée est la meilleure façon de casser
des barrières totalement dépassé et il
faut accentuer ce mouvement dont le
rapport qui nous a été présenté il y
avait cinq grandes catégories de
critiques
les premières c'était le détournement
fiscale massive et nous avons rencontré
les gros services fiscaux de plusieurs
départements particulièrement concernée
par la recherche développement et ce
constat présenté par madame rapporteur a
été évoquée mais jamais observée par les
services et nous avons auditionné
monsieur muscle
budget et des finances publiques reçues
et care qui nous a confirmé que le sujet
était particulier étaient parfaitement
maîtrisés et qui peut croire que dans
notre pays
l'administration fiscale n'est pas si ce
n'est pas capable de contrôler quelque
chose présentés comme des détournements
massifs
bien sûr une difficulté technique a été
souvent évoqué qui est le contrôle du
périmètre de la recherche
parce qu'en un inspecteur des impôts
d'efforts pas forcément un scientifique
est en réalité pour que ça fonctionne il
faut un tandem un expert nommé par le
ministre de la recherche et du
développement
et naturellement responsable des
services fiscaux et nous avons une
difficulté c'est des experts par assez
nombreux mais ça ne justifie pas là non
plus l'idée de condamner le dispositif
en deuxième critique en sus des
détournements longuement démontré comme
étant fictifs
madame la rapporteur a souvent soulevé
une autre critique il n'y aurait aucune
corrélation entre le cir les créations
d'emplois je rappellerai juste donc lors
de son audition monsieur marc reymann
directeur technique en charge de la
recherche et de l'innovation du groupe
thalès du vent d'entreprise français
nous a déclaré que le recrutement d'un
emploi recherche et technologie induit
la création de 10 emplois en
développement et en production
au surplus la réforme de 2008 a fait
passer le nombre des entreprises
bénéficiant du cir de 5000 à 20000 on
est donc loin des 40 entreprises du cac
40 que l'on met toujours en avant comme
étant les grands des tourneurs autre
critique le cir profiterait plus aux
grandes entreprises qu'aux pme
certes les grandes entreprises
totalisent pratiquement 60% des dépenses
de recherche développement en france
mais elle perçoit en valeur plus de
crédit d'impôt recherche mois que les
pme voilà le ratio en probation des
dépenses les pme sont financés à hauteur
de 30% les outils entreprises
intermédiaires à hauteur de 21 et les
grandes entreprises touchent à peu près
13 % de leurs dépenses et beaucoup
d'entre elles ne vont pas jusqu'au
plafond loin de là
le nombreuses études ont démontré aussi
que le cir est aussi efficace pour les
unes comme pour les autres même si bien
sûr on peut toujours trouver quelques
cas particuliers en annexe à la fraude
une critique aussi sur l'optimisation
fiscale du cir par des grands groupes
notamment par l'utilisation des filiales
pour répartir sur celle-ci des dépenses
de recherche développement et se
soustraire à la limitation du taux 5
portant de la 100 millions d'euros de
dépenses déclaré
peu de groupes moins de dix utilisent
des filiales dans notre pays aux maisons
mères si ces types de de fer faut-il
qu'ils aient un tel dispositif et sur
cette thématique particulière des
filiales
je dénonce un reportage télévisé sur
france 2 complètement à charge et
parfaitement mensonger à une heure de
grande écoute
alors que la commission denquête
semblait se diriger vers des conclusions
justes et quasi unanime
monsieur pujadas par pur hasard annoncé
comme une entreprise publique
renault utiliser des filiales comme
pompe à fric au détriment du fisc or
renault dans notre pays développent 75%
sa revanche en développement en france
alors qu'il n'y vont plus que 20 % sa
production
quelle gifle pour monsieur pujadas de
voir le succès de la voiture connectée
considéré par sept experts comme un
véhicule détournant l'argent public
alors qu'en ce moment même au consumer
electronics show se sont toutes les
technologies autour de la voiture
connectée qui font le succès de
nombreuses startups françaises reconnues
comme les plus créatives et les plus
performantes
la filière présenté comme une pompe à
fric par l'éminent présentateur est
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues un
véritable succès à du cl de la france un
dispositif plus efficace
l'observatoire du cir a mis en avant un
effet d'entraînement du dispositif un
euro du cir supplémentaires investis par
l'état
sa campagne de 25 euros supplémentaires
accomplies par les entreprises mesurer
l'efficacité du dispositif s'est vérifié
il remplit son objectif augmenter
l'investissement en recherche
développement et c'est le cas mes chers
collègues mon collègue berson d'ailleurs
rapporteur de la commission des finances
sur ce sujet avait estimé au surplus
la croissance du pub à long terme
bénéficier d'une sueur sur action de 0
5%
c'est donc un enjeu important tant
vis-à-vis de notre taux de croissance
que de notre compétitivité
nos recommandations car nous en avions
sur lesquels nous gérons tu es tu
d'accord d'abord faciliter l'élaboration
des dossiers cyr qui sont complexes
renforcer le nombre d'experts aux jeunes
est indiquée pour avoir une meilleure
des ternes ans pour avoir durant un
périmètre scientifique de recherche bien
établie et incontestable vérifiez aussi
le rôle de la sous traitance
le cir doit être exclusivement attribuée
à l'auteur des recherches ce qu'ils
clarifient naturellement le rapport
entre donneurs d'ordre et sous traitants
crée aussi un comité de conciliation
ce que ne pour examiner les problèmes
fiscaux ce que nous a accordé monsieur
eckert et la commission en bois servi à
ceux ci redéfinir le conseil de cabinet
de conseil privilégié l'écosystème ce
que préconisent les grands groupes comme
total pour les cirés brevets bien sûr
qu'il ya des problèmes commerciaux de
brevets mais le problème n'est pas tant
celui ci que de la nécessité pour notre
pays de combler le retard d'aujourd'hui
et demain retrouvez l'impact d'un pays
innovant il est préférable d'assurer
longévité et une visibilité aux
entreprises sur un dispositif qui a par
effet de levier démontré ses moyens ses
résultats et je dirais mais chers
collègues en disant que ce dispositif a
été imaginé par mesures par le
gouvernement de monsieur pierre mauroy
elle a été modernisée par celui de
monsieur fillon il ya quand même de
plumeau les auteurs merci monsieur
delattre
la parole est à monsieur michel cano v
pour le groupe udi uc
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues je voudrais
tout d'abord commencé par remercier le
groupe crc d'avoir demandé cette
commission d' enquête sur le crédit
d'impôt recherche
les membres du groupe d y sont
effectivement particulièrement attaché à
ce que l'effort de l'action publique
soit orientée autant que possible vers
l'emploi et nous nous réjouissions de la
création de cette commission d'enquêté
je tiens particulièrement à féliciter le
président francis delattre qui a mené
cette commission des requêtes de mad m
remercie aussi bien entendu madame la
rapporteure générale brigitte gonthier
maurin qui nous a permis aussi d'aller
au fond au fond des choses sur ce
dossier alors qu at on constaté déjà on
ne peut pas être d'accord a priori comme
vient de l'évoquer
francis delattre avec l'intitulé qui
avait été retenu pour cette commission
denquête en commission denquête sur la
réalité du détournement du crédit impôt
recherche
je crois que ce n'est pas une façon
d'appréhender les choses a fortiori
lorsque dans notre pays on s'aperçoit
que tout doit être fait en direction de
l'emploi n'est ce pas monsieur le
ministre que nous devons vraiment mettre
toutes nos forces dans la bataille
non nous avons pu par le biais de cette
commission denquête est aujourd'hui
également approfondir le débat sur
l'intérêt du crédit impôt recherche
d'autres pays
cela a été dit tout à l'heure mais je le
rappelle c'est 5 milliards et demi de
crédit d'impôts ainsi octroyé ce sont 21
mille entreprises bénéficiaires
aujourd'hui dont 90% sont des pme 90%
la réalité n'est pas celle que l'on
voulait voudrait nous faire croire à
considérer que ce sont les grands
groupes qui s'approprie le crédit impôt
recherche non sur les 5 milliards et
demi les grands groupes bénéficient de 2
4 milliards d'euros de crédit impôt
recherche donc ça veut dire que la plus
grande masse elle est dédiée aux petites
et moyennes entreprises
et on sait bien que c'est à noter
important quasiment tous les
l'orateur qui sont intervenus durant les
débats de la commission d'accueil nous
ont dit combien cet outil était
particulièrement pertinent pour le
développement des entreprises
c'est vrai que nous avons eu à supporter
francis delattre l'a dit à l'instant
aussi un reportage télévisé mettant à
charge un grand constructeur national de
véhicules il y en a trois et il y en a
deux qui sont connues et puis un que qui
inaugure une nouvelle usine dans le
finistère à quimper vendredi je veux
parler de du groupe bolloré qui
développe aussi la l'assemblage de
véhicules électriques dans notre pays et
qu'il convient aussi d'encourager le
crédit impôt recherche y concourent il
concourt effectivement un grand nombre
d'emplois créés à 6 et c'est important
et donc un reportage à charge
effectivement sur un grand groupe
industriel parce que le crédit impôt
recherche il faut le rappeler
il concerne à 60% des entreprises dans
le secteur de l'industrie dans le
secteur de l'industrie
ce sur quoi nous avons des faiblesses
avérées et ce sur quoi il faut
effectivement que nous portions l'effort
c'est bien clair et donc comme francis
delattre l'évoqué aussi tout à l'heure
effectivement ce grand groupe industriel
a choisi de concentrer en france des
trois quarts de ses efforts de recherche
qui sont importants et pour s'adapter au
marché il faut constamment pouvoir
effectuer des efforts de recherche
ils sont conséquents 2 milliards d'euros
que consacre ce groupe a à la recherche
dont les trois quarts comme je
l'évoquais ici dans notre pays et donc
c'est fort justement que les membres du
groupe des ics y participer à la
commission denquête n'ont absolument pas
pu adopter les conclusions que nous
proposait la rapporteure non il faut il
faut prendre conscience que la réalité
ce n'est pas du détournement de crédit
impôt recherche
mais au contraire que c'est un outil qui
certes particulièrement les entreprises
particulièrement les petites entreprises
pour leur développement pour adapter
leurs produits aux attentes des
consommateurs et c'est absolument
nécessaire et s'il n'y avait pas cet
outil là que nous envient le monde
entier tout le monde nous dit mais il y
a en france les conditions les
meilleures pour accueillir les
chercheurs et faisons faisons attention
monsieur le ministre à ce que nous
soyons pas rattrapé par les autres qui
effectivement voyant l'intérêt de ce
dispositif est bien essaye de le copier
voire de le rendre encore plus attractif
dans leur pays et donc il faut que nous
ayons constamment nous un temps d'avancé
sur le sujet et je disais donc les
membres du groupe
udi qui ont participé à cette formation
de requêtes n'ont absolument pas pu
adopter des conclusions parce que nous
considérons effectivement que cet outil
est absolument nécessaire
stratégiquement il est également je vous
rappelle que la france avait validé la
stratégie de lisbonne qui visait à ce
que 3% du produit intérieur but brut
soit consacrée aux dépenses intérieures
de recherche et de développement des
entreprises
quel est le constat aujourd'hui le
constat c'est qu'on n'y est pas on peut
estimer grosso modo que le pib étant un
peu plus de 2000 milliards aujourd'hui
la recherche privée en france concernent
environ 30 milliards d'euros la
recherche publique c'est de l'ordre de
15 milliards d'euros ça veut dire qu'on
n'est pas encore aux 3% du pib que nous
devrions nous fixer et monsieur le
ministre vous connaissez bien
ces questions de recherche vous savez
bien qu'il faut que l'on n'aille plus en
avant en la matière sans quoi
effectivement nos entreprises ne seront
pas s'adapter et donc il est clair que
nous avons besoin de poursuivre cet
effort et on sait bien que l'action
publique ne pourra permettre à elle
seule compte tenu de l'état de nos
finances publiques il faut le rappeler
aussi ici particulièrement dégradé
l'action publique ne pourra à elle seule
permettre d'atteindre cet objectif
ambitieux mais ô combien
nécessaire et donc ceci veut dire qu'il
faut encourager les entreprises à
pouvoir s'y engager tout à fait
résolument et c'est l'objet du crédit
impôt recherche
créé en 1983 donc cela fait très
longtemps mais topi en 2008
prenons un chiffre en 2007 il y avait
deux cent seize mille chercheurs en 2012
il y avait pratiquement 250 me de ça
veut dire que l'effort fait à travers le
crédit impôt recherche a permis
d'augmenter les moyens humains dédiés à
la recherche dans notre pays donc
effectivement l'emploi dans notre pays
et ça c'est particulièrement important
parce qu'elle avec plus de 5 millions de
demandeurs d'emploi nous ne pouvons
continuer à regarder les autres agir il
faut aussi que nous nous soyons
particulièrement victor hugo rue là
dessus et donc le groupe udi on le dit
très clairement est attaché à ce que
dans notre pays il y ait de la stabilité
fiscale
c'est aussi ce que nous ont demandé les
entrepreneurs que nous avons auditionné
pendant cette commission denquête de la
stabilité fiscale ça veut dire qu'il ne
faut pas en permanence remettre sur la
table les conditions dans lesquelles
fonctionnent des dispositifs c'est la
condition par laquelle seules les
entreprises pourront continuer à se
développer en france a déposé des
brevets et a donc à préparer l'avenir en
tout cas le groupe id y est très
clairement en faveur de ce dispositif
merci de votre attention
la parole est à monsieur michel berson
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame le rapporteur chars
collègues
si l'existence du crédit d'impôt
recherche n'est plus aujourd'hui remis
en cause
le cirque continue à faire débat
comme l'a montré la commission d'
enquête du sénat si l'efficacité du cir
semble aujourd'hui communément reconnu
nombre de critiques restent vives
optimisation fiscale effet d'aubaine
pour les grands groupes détournement de
son objet transformée en financement de
trésorerie pour les pme contrôle fiscal
insuffisant pour lézan excessif pour les
autres coûts trop élevés pour l'état
je limiterai ici mon propos à l'analyse
des effets du crédit d'impôt recherche
sur les dépenses de recherche des
entreprises françaises
c'est à dire à l'analyse de l'efficacité
du dispositif en 2016
la créance du cir devrait dépasser les
5,5 milliards d'euros
seconde dépenses fiscales de l'état
après le cic eux le coût du cir
représentent 40% des 14 milliards du
budget de l'état consacré à la recherche
publique
c'est le dispositif de soutien public à
la recherche privée le plus favorable et
des pays de l' ocde il représente 0 26%
du pib' devant les 0 1 21% du canada en
effet avec la réforme du cir en 2008 le
nombre d'entreprises bénéficiaires a
doublé en sept ans pour atteindre en
le chiffre de 21 mille cinq cents et sur
la même période la créance du cir a
triplé de 1,7 à 5,5 milliards niveau qui
semble maintenant se stabiliser
parallèlement à la croissance du cir
les dépenses de recherche des
entreprises ont progressé entre 2008 et
2014 de 24,1
7 à 30 5 milliards d'euros excusez moi
cet effort d'investissement des
entreprises est égal à 1,5 pour cent du
pipe français contre 2,18 % en allemagne
taux supérieur à l'objectif européen de
2%
pourquoi la france est-elle loin de cet
objectif en dépit de l'importance du
crédit d'impôt recherche qui en
allemagne n'existe pas pour deux raisons
d'abord pour une raison fiscale en
allemagne le taux d'imposition des
sociétés est de 30 % contre 38 % en
france qui a fait le choix d'un taux
plus élevé d'imposition mais assorti
d'exonérations et de déductions fiscales
comme le crédit d'impôt recherche
ensuite et surtout pour une raison
économique depuis la fin des années 90
la france a connu une
désindustrialisation croissante accéléré
par la crise de 2008
ainsi de 2001 2012 la part de
l'industrie dans le pib français a
régressé de 13,3 à 12 et demi pour cent
alors qu'elle est restée stable en
allemagne à hauteur de 25%
là réside la principale explication de
la faiblesse des dépenses de r&d des
entreprises en france car dans tous les
pays
l'essentiel de la recherche privée se
fait dans les entreprises industrielles
parallèlement à cette
désindustrialisation
les dépenses de recherche aurait dû donc
mécaniquement fléchir
or que constate-t-on entre 2008 année du
début de la crise
mais aussi première année d'application
de la réforme du cir et 2014
la dépense de recherche des entreprises
françaises a augmenté de 24,7 à 35
milliards d'euros soit 2 20%
la plus forte progression observée en
europe durant cette période comme le
démontre un rapport du ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui fait autorité
cette progression s'explique par la
croissance de l'intensité en r&d de
l'industrie française c'est à dire du
ratio autres dépenses de r&d et chiffre
d'affaires des entreprises industrielles
un rapport qui aujourd'hui est en france
légèrement supérieur à celui de
l'allemagne
finalement en france ce qui est en cause
ce n'est pas l'effort de recherche des
entreprises
c'est le poids élevé dans notre pipe des
secteurs à faible intensité de recherche
comme le btp l'agroalimentaire ou
l'énergie
deux conclusions peuvent être tirées de
ce constat
premièrement la hausse de l'intensité en
r&d des entreprises françaises a plus
que compensé l'impact négatif de la
désindustrialisation
mais globalement la recherche reste
pénalisé par la faiblesse du socle
industriel français deuxièmement le
crédit d'impôt recherche en soutenant
l'effort de recherche des entreprises a
produit un effet anti crise il a évité
une réduction des dépenses de r&d
notamment depuis 2008 précisément année
de mise en oeuvre de la réforme du cir
cette analyse démontrant l'efficacité du
cir pourrait être complétée par les
résultats convergents de plusieurs
études économétriques concluant un effet
positif du cir sur les dépenses de r&d
des entreprises
en effet l'un des indicateurs annuels de
performance des dépenses de l'état
présentés dans les documents budgétaires
du ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche montrent un effet
d'addition du cir qui excluent toute
hypothèse d'effet d'aubaine un euro de
cir engendrerait 1,30 euro de r&d privés
supplémentaires
le crédit d'impôt recherche s'avère
efficace mais la forte expansion du cir
impose une amélioration du contrôle de
son utilisation notamment une plus
grande cohérence dans l'action de
l'administration fiscale et des experts
du ministère de la recherche qui
effectuent conjointement les contrôles
de même la forte expansion du cir
nécessite une maîtrise de son coûte
ce que l'état consent aux entreprises en
crédit d'impôt recherche pour se tenir
la recherche privée
il n'en disposent pas pour financer les
dotations budgétaires de la recherche
publique
aussi aujourd'hui la question se pose de
la pertinence de la répartition de
l'effort annuel de l'état entre les 14
milliards de dotations budgétaires pour
développer la recherche publique et les
5,5 milliards du crédit d'impôt
recherche pour soutenir la recherche
privée les 14,1 les 14 et 15 5 milliards
c'est-à-dire les 19,5 milliards d'euros
mobilisés par l'état sont à comparer aux
30,5 milliards de dépenses annuelles de
recherche des entreprises qu'elle ne
finance d'ailleurs qu'à hauteur de 25
milliards contenu des 5 5 milliards de
crédit d'impôt recherche
à la lumière de ces chiffres on comprend
que s'exprime de plus en plus monsieur
le ministre le souhait d'un
rééquilibrage des financements de l'état
au profit de la recherche publique en
limitant le coût du cir la
sanctuarisation du cir décidée par le
président de la république empêche
aujourd'hui toute évolution toute
amélioration du dispositif par exemple
permettre aux sociétés sous traitantes
agréé de bénéficier du cir alors même
que leurs donneurs d'ordres n'en
bénéficient pas ou bien conditionnés
dans les grands groupes
l'application du taux du cir de 5%
al embauche de docteur cependant et j'en
terminerai par là en m'excusant d'avoir
dépassé quelque peu mon temps imparti
cependant compte tenu des enjeux du
financement de la recherche en france
la réforme du crédit d'impôt recherche
nous paraît inéluctable
c'est ce que pensent les membres du
groupe socialiste merci merci on vous a
laissé le temple du temps de la
recherche des pages
vais donner la parole à madame corinne
bouchoux pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues madame la
rapporteure de feu notre rapport je
remercie tout d'abord vivement le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen
d'avoir mis à l'ordre du jour ce débat
sur un thème important à savoir les
incidences du crédit impôt recherche sur
la situation de l'emploi et de la
recherche dans notre pays compte tenu de
l'impact sur nos finances de ce
dispositif cela a été dit plus de 5
milliards d'euros
quoi de plus pertinent que de voir où va
l'argent c'est pourquoi je ne peux que
regretter vivement que la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale sur le sujet que
nous avons évoqué ce soit fait hara-kiri
faisant disparaître le rapport les
conclusions et les auditions c'est une
forme de masochisme sur lequel peut être
un jour il faudra s'interroger alors
puisque l'on m'a assuré que le travail
n'existe plus le rapport n'existe plus
les archives n'existe plus je vais me
fonder pour mon propos sur ce qui existe
encore
l'association science en marche a
produit un réel travail d'investigation
avec des sources accessibles à ceux qui
le souhaitent sur internet
ce qu'ils écrivent propose une
photographie tout à fait précieuse
impartiale et claire de ce qu'est le
crédit impôt recherche vers où il va de
sa progression et y compris des marges
d'amélioration possibles pour
l'améliorer analysés par mes
prédécesseurs comme un dopant comme un
facteur d'innovation voir par d'autres
comme un facteur d'attractivité un
facteur j'ai entendu dans nos couloirs
pour rester sexy dans l'économie
mondiale il faut être honnête mes chers
collègues personne ici ne voulait que ce
rapport soit adoptée il y avait un
accord hors mis dans deux petites
familles politiques pour que par tout
moyen de forme de fonds de
rebondissements télévisuelle ce rapport
soit torpillée et à cet égard
effectivement nous avons eu une
présidence brillante et réussi
l'objectif n'a pas été atteint sur le
crédit impôt recherche mais il a été
atteint sur la sortie du rapport
lorsque l'on y regarde d'un petit peu
plus près que peut-on dire de ces 5,5
milliards d'impôts certains ont signalé
effectivement qu'il profitait quand même
proportionnellement beaucoup aux grands
groupes même si ça n'est pas réservé au
cac 40
évidemment il a été aussi montré que
c'était un facteur pour attirer dans
certains domaines des entreprises
internationales qui voit et elles le
disent un facteur d'attractivité de nos
territoires mais est ce le sens d'un
crédit d'impôt recherche c'est la
question qu'on pourrait se poser qu'il
faille rendre attractif notre territoire
est un fait mais est-ce que ça doit
passer par ce biais là ensuite si on
regarde un petit peu de près la question
de l'emploi on peut être un petit peu
plus critique par exemple
en 2011 seuls 12% des chercheurs en
entreprise et est titulaire d'un
doctorat contre 55 diplômé d'une école
d'ingénieur ou d'une grande école est-ce
que grâce au crédit impôt recherche la
situation des docteurs en entreprises
s'est améliorée pas du tout
malheureusement ce titre qui est le plus
important reconnu au niveau
international reste en france encore peu
attractif et là dans ce domaine le
crédit impôt recherche a été on va le
dire relativement inopérant ensuite le
crédit impôt recherche de vrais c'est un
but aider à la promotion de la r&d privé
le bilan est il si positif que ce qui a
été dit nous persistons à penser comme
le comité pour la stratégie nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur qui a vendu un
rapport extrêmement intéressant qu'il
faut absolument modifier la tendance
actuelle et faire en sorte qu'il y ait
plus de vrai docteur et de vrais emplois
scientifiques et pas de requalification
comme par exemple dans le secteur
bancaire dans un certain nombre de
secteurs
hourrabi en crédit impôt recherche des
choses qui ne le sont pas et nous le
savons tous pour dire les choses
également il faut reprendre le rapport
de la cour des comptes de 2013 qui
signalaient déjà que l'efficacité du
crédit impôt recherche
au regard de son objectif principal
d'augmentation de la dépenses de r&d des
entreprises est difficile à établir et
l'évolution de cette dépense n'est pas à
se joue en proportion de l'avantagé
fiscal accordé et c'est bien là le
problème il ne disons pas que le
seigneur ne sert à rien nous disons que
vu ce qu'on met le résultat est
extrêmement modeste et donc il doit être
interrogé
par le législateur que nous sommes je
vous invite aussi à consulter le rapport
de l'association séance en marche
présenté le 6 avril 2015 à notre
commission mais qui n'existe plus il a
été publié sur le site de cette
association et qui montre bien l'effet
de levier dans les entreprises de moins
de 500 salariés mais également les
causes mitigé dans les grandes
entreprises et dans certains secteurs
qui en profite plus que d'autres pour le
dire autrement le crédit impôt recherche
favorise massivement la recherche dual
le nucléaire des secteurs dont on doit
pouvoir débattre sereinement c'est aussi
cela qui a gêné dans la mission que vous
avez diligentée enfin je pense qu'il
faut accepter d'avoir une vision
prospective du crédit impôt recherche ne
vous proposons pas sa suppression
nous disons simplement qu'on marche sur
la tête c'est une niche qui permet dans
un certain nombre de cas des
optimisations nous avons une proposition
à vous faire tournons nous vers la
transition écologique ça tombe bien il y
a eu la coop 21 et monsieur le ministre
nous aimerions vivement que le seiller
puisqu'il existe soit en soit destinée
massivement à la transition écologique
permettent de faire évoluer notre tissu
industriel parce que c'est ça qui est
très important est que nous puissions
avoir un crédit d'impôt recherche
vertueux qui permettent de modifier la
société et non pas de stabiliser des
rentes de situation enfin dernière
question et j'aimerais un jour on ne
nous reproche pas au niveau européen que
notre crédit impôt recherche dont nous
abusons allègrement pose des problèmes
nous avons alerté plusieurs fois à ce
sujet et puis dernier point et ce sera
le mot de la fin
faut-il que nous ayons dit des choses
taboues pour que totalement nous à nyon
en quelques minutes
quatre à six mois de recherche des
dizaines peut être des centaines
d'heures d'audition de production de
savoir intellectuel et intelligent donc
moi je m'en remets aux citoyens aux
journalistes aux enseignants chercheurs
qui pourront poursuivre notre travail
que nous avons amorcé je vous remercie
de votre attention
merci madame corinne bouchoux en
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
devraient
le réjouir de ce débat sur les
incidences du cir pour l'emploi et la
recherche dans notre pays vous
connaissez sur ce sujet la position
gouvernementale de stabiliser ce
dispositif mais c'est stabilité
n'interdit pas bien au contraire qu'on
s'interroge quand on analyse qu'on
évalue l'impact d'un dispositif
budgétaire important pour pour le pays
se stabilise ça veut pas dire tourner la
tête et dire circulez ya rien à voir
mais au contraire prendre le temps de
mesurer les impacts micro économique de
ce dispositif est de mener les débats
que qui ont lieu notamment au parlement
il est bien naturel que dans ses
prérogatives le parlement s'intéresse à
une dépense fiscale de cette importance
je voudrais donc afin que nous
partagions de diagnostic reprendre ici
un certain nombre d éléments qui ont été
évoqués et m'appuyant sur de très
nombreux rapports parlementaires étude
publiée récemment identifié deux ou
trois problématiques de moyen terme
relatives à ce dispositif
comme vous le savez comme certains
d'entre vous la plupart l'ont souligné
dollar peu la recherche repose sur deux
piliers la recherche publique et celle
des entreprises
notre pays vous l'avez dit se
singularise par une répartition des
dépenses de recherche dans laquelle la
recherche publique représente une part
importante comparable à la moyenne des
pays de l'osce et des oeufs et
corrélativement dans laquelle les
dépenses de recherche privé une part
moins importante alors que nos dépenses
de recherche représente un total de 2000
28 % du pib en 2014
les dépenses de recherche publique
représente 0,8 pour cent de la richesse
nationale les dépenses privées 1,48 % à
comparer par exemple au 2% de pib en
allemagne quand les dépenses publiques
sont sensiblement comparable au nôtre et
il ya là une préoccupation des éléments
d'ailleurs d'annalynne nous ont été
donnés dans ce débat y compris tout à
l'heure travers l'interview
sur très très fine de 2 michel berson il
ya là une problématique très importante
pour la structure économique industriel
de notre pays ce problème n'est pas
nouveau
vous l'avez rappelé et gouvernement de
pierre mauroy qui a créé le crédit
d'impôt recherche en 83 afin que les
entreprises s'engagent davantage dans
les activités de recherche et de
développement à cette époque les
entreprises françaises consacré 0,83
pour cent de leur pib à la r d
quand les entreprises allemandes
dépenses est déjà 1,43 % les entreprises
américaines 1,24 pour cent les
entreprises japonaises 1,62 pour et donc
près de vingt années après cette date
le trente années après cette date pardon
ce qu'au niveau des dépenses de
recherche privée a heureusement
progresser en france il a progressé
partout ailleurs ce qui fait que l'écart
demeure entre la france et ses
principaux partenaires écart qui se
justifie probablement en effet par une
structure économique une part de
l'industrie différentes en france de ce
qu'elle est dans les pays que j'ai cités
ce dispositif est devenu le dispositif
le plus important dont dispose l'état
pour inciter les entreprises à accroître
leurs efforts de r&d il a subi de
nombreuses modifications la principale
étant vous l'avez évoqué aussi celle de
la réforme de 2008 cette réforme a
largement ouvert le dispositif ce qui
conduit désormais nombreuses entreprises
a déclaré des dépenses éligibles au cir
ce crédit d'impôt ce crédit d'impôt a
été de nombreuses fois analysées il a
fait l'objet de nombreux rapports
parlementaire et c'est sur l'ensemble de
ses analyses ses rapports des
parlementaires que je voudrais m'appuyer
pour donner des éléments factuels qui
nous permettent au moins de partager un
diagnostic commun avant que bien
naturellement les les points de vue
s'expriment la dépense elle était de 5,7
milliards en 2014 sur les dépenses 2013
en prenant en compte la nouveauté que
fut le crédit d'impôt innovation pour un
montant de 74 millions d'euros
en déduisant ce dispositif le cir
atteints dont je crois que nous sommes
d'accord sur les chiffres
un montant de 5,5 5 milliards 567
millions 2014 contre 5 milliards 609
millions en 2013 bref ce dispositif
après avoir connu une croissance
importante entre 2008 et 2012 est
désormais rentré dans une phase de
maturité et ne progresse plus en montant
qui sont les bénéficiaires du cir faut
les analyser en fonction de la nature
des entreprises bénéficiaires et de leur
taille
on dit trop souvent que seules les
grandes entreprises sont bénéficiaires
du cir la réalité de fait bien plus
nuance en ce qui concerne la nature des
entreprises on constate que des
entreprises de toutes tailles y compris
les plus petites bénéficie du cir par
exemple plus de 6000 entreprises de
moins de dix salariés bénéficient du cir
avec une créance moyenne de 50 kg euros
les entreprises de moins de 250 salariés
représentent 31% des dépenses fiscales
au titre du cir alors qu'elle n'effectue
que 28 7% des dépenses de recherche
privée de l'autre côté du spectre les
grandes entreprises de plus de 5000
salariés réalisent 39 5% des dépenses de
recherche privés reçoivent 34 5% du cir
cette différence s'explique notamment
par le taux de réduit de cire au delà du
seuil de 100 millions d'euros
auquel vous avez fait référence le cir
concerne donc bien désormais beaucoup
plus que les grandes entreprises mais il
exerce aussi un effet redistributif en
direction des plus petites entreprises
qui bénéficient d'une part de sir plus
important que leur contribution aux
dépenses de recherche en ce qui concerne
les secteurs d'activité l'industrie
collet presque les deux tiers de la
créance 61% de la créance les services
36% de 7
parmi les services la majorité va aussi
secteur des services informatiques et le
service d'architecturé et d'ingénierie
ce qui est frappant c'est alors que le
secteur industriel a fortement baissé
entre 2002 et 2012 de 16 8% du pib' à 12
5% du pipe désormais ce secteur
concentre la majorité des dépenses de
r&d
les dépenses de r&d ont d'ailleurs
continué à augmenter dans ce secteur
dans notre pays on peut y voir donc
l'effet très fort de du cir même si bien
sûr d'autres causes comme la montée en
gamme de la production en est une autre
l'impact du cir se mesure enfin aussi au
nombre des investisseurs étrangers qui
ont implanté des centres de recherche et
développement en france ce nombre est
important très important il est passé de
45 implantation en 2012 à 72% en 72
pardon en 2014 et vous avez tous à
l'esprit des investisseurs étrangers de
renom qui ont choisi la france comme
plateforme de recherche et développement
européennes au regard notamment de ce
dispositif qui est 13h attractif
on entend parfois que l'augmentation du
cir serait un contrôle et cela ne
correspond pas
la réalité observée c'est pourquoi le
président de la république a choisi de
garantir la stabilité fiscale afin de
permettre aux entreprises d'avoir une
prévisibilité surtout en matière de
recherche qui nécessite une
planification sur sur dans la durée de
leur cadre fiscal c'est d'autant plus
important quand on parle de r&d dans un
contexte de forte crise les éléments
dont nous disposons montrent aussi que
la dépense de r d privée a légèrement
augmenté depuis 2010 disons les choses
autrement le sirha à l'évidence jouer un
rôle de stabilisateur des dépenses de
recherche dans notre pays y compris
contra cyclique
je roule donc nous devons nous réjouir
sur tous les bancs et de ce point de vue
là à contribuer à soutenir l' embauche
de docteurs dans le secteur privé il ya
d'ailleurs plus de 33000 serrures je
crois que quelqu'un leur a rappelé leur
madame laborde probablement de plus dans
notre pays depuis 2008
néanmoins il convient de dévaluer avec
sérieux et surtout avec transparence
l'impact du sien et nous n'avons rien à
craindre de cette transmanche je vais
même vous dire dans quelques minutes que
nous souhaitons l'encourager cette
stabilité
donne en effet le temps d'une évaluation
sérieuse et de ce point de vue là le
ministère à des travaux d'évaluation
très précis qui ont été lancées par un
jeune bien fait rage ou que que je
poursuis est de ce point de vue là le
ministère recommande des études à des
chercheurs extérieurs lance des enquêtes
micro auprès des entreprises entreprend
lui-même des analyses statistiques et
présente des synthèses des résultats le
ministère a ainsi depuis plusieurs
années encourager les travaux de
recherche sur le site en mettant les
données de la base de données relatives
à ce dispositif à la disposition des
chercheurs
plusieurs équipes re de recherche
travaille actuellement sur ces données
cette mise à disposition des données
s'effectue dans le cadre de la procédure
général concernant les données
d'enquêtés les données fiscales qui
prévoit un accord de la commission du
secret l'utilisation par les chercheurs
des centres d'accès à distance
plusieurs équipes au fait y compris
récemment des demandes dans ce cadre je
tiens à me porter garant du soutien à
ces demandes
je l' ai déjà fait auprès d'associations
qui réclamaient une plus grande
transparence concernant le cir ces
demandes sont absolument légitimes elles
devront naturellement donné lieu à des
traitement respectueux des protocoles de
recherche scientifique de rapports
d'évaluation aussi été publiés ces
dernières années le rapport publié en
2014 développement et impacts du crédit
d'impôt recherche 2003 2011 a fait le
point sur l'ensemble des résultats des
études menées depuis 2005 2006 les
études d'impact du cir ce sont d'abord
concentrés sur l'objet principal du cir
l'augmentation des dépenses de r&d des
entreprises
les études ont utilisé plusieurs
méthodes elles convergent tout pour
indiquer que le cir a un effet
d'addition sur les dépenses de r&d des
entreprises c'est à dire qu'un euro de
cir entraîne un euros de dépenses de r&d
supplémentaires 1 euro 1,7 à peu près le
chiffre que tout le monde désormais sur
le chiffre sur lequel tout le monde 50
le dernier rapport confié à deux
chercheurs vient d'être publié il porte
sur l'évaluation de l'impact spécifique
du dispositif jeunes docteurs
le de cirque comporte en effet une
disposition particulièrement favorable
lambeaux de docteurs dans des fonctions
de rede pour un premier cd des
dispositifs jeunes docteurs une
entreprise au passage ce n'est pas assez
connue qui en bouche un docteur pour son
premier cd lui dans une activité voilà
pour cette séance sur le crédit impôt
recherche à place au direct sur